do you feel like you guys get the credit
for some of the business because I feel
like you guys set up some business
models that other artists like I I you
know I've told this to Tech 9 Tech's my
brother love Tech but I feel like Tech
and strange get credit for a lot of the
[__] that y'all were doing like years
prior you know what I mean like I
discovered Tech through you guys you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah man me
and
man we almost we almost went to war you
know what I'm saying right because it it
got um it was 2017 you know what I'm
saying and that was a a pivotal year in
the Jugo lore because the number 17 is
is is everything that's the only
calendar year with 17 in it in all in
the Jug's lives you know so anyway that
year we were uh also suing the FBI
because they put us on the [__] gang
list they put jug as a gang you know so
we're doing March on Washington and all
this [__] right and
um Tech goes on Hot
97 and he's telling stories about
fictitious [__] basically rumor [__]
he's talking about like a a raw dog line
at the Gathering you know like [__]
50 ninjas gang banging a chick or
whatever that [__] ain't you know what
I'm saying it's it that [__] is ain't
true you know what I mean I've heard
I've heard of some of the weird [__]
that's at the the Gathering that's
pretty gnarly say
no no no I'm not mad about tech no more
but the way he put it down it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't our our what
we were doing you know so it wasn't
helping what you guys had going on at
that time exactly right and the other
thing was we were doing a concert there
we played uh Rudy where did we play
right at the Lincoln Memorial yeah right
and um it was a free concert right and I
during the march we did we marched on
Washington it like [__] thousand
thousand of jug out there we did a March
cuz this is we don't know how else to
[__] they said there a gang it was
insane you you guys had by 2017 you were
on the gang list for years by that point
right yeah since 11 since it happened in
2011 but here's the thing you got to
understand bro in certain parts of the
country when people are on a [__]
gang list like if a Jugo gets pulled
over and he he [__] suddenly on a
gang list you know what I'm saying it's
a problem he might be having a custody
battle for his kids right and his wife
his ex-wife attorney like this is a gang
member according to the government of
United States tattoo or something
according to the government of United
States you know what I mean like this
[__] was [__] it [__] up uh D was a
probation officer for 15 years right
when that gang resonate thing came out
uh when we made the top 10 gangs she
[__] got fired I mean right in the
pink slip it was like we saw it on your
Facebook you know what I mean you're out
of here you know what I mean like wow so
ruined a lot of people's lives people
were getting thrown out of the military
bro I always tell people told them re uh
um cover their tattoos or have them
removed I say this all the time I say
they are real teachers teaching our kids
right now with Hatcher man tattoos in
America but anyway the point was um but
the tech tech had so so many Jugo fans
right tons yeah you guys share so many
fans he should have played that concert
you get what I'm saying so I asked him I
felt like it was way in Advan you know
what I mean but I asked them to play the
concert like come do this man we're
paying back we're going through this
they're putting this [__] the [__] on
jugal you know what I mean it's really
[__] lives up we don't know how else
to combat it by except doing this
marching concert you know and uh we
tried suing them [__] four times and
got thrown out of court suing the FBI
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying so um
cuz you talks about merchandise and
expenses and Hot Topics guess when that
ended when 201 201 the second that gang
year like [__] out of here all that [__]
it totally [__] our [__] up you know
what I mean and it's like we're just
chilling here
Independent Business artists you know
what I'm saying what the [__] is the
problem you know what I mean like what
is any it's so outrageous yet we just
lost yeah you know what I'm saying so so
are you guys still on that list the list
don't exist no more it came out in 2011
yeah right that was the only year they
ever announced a list like that right
you know what I'm saying so you guys are
on that list with like the Crips the
Bloods probably Hell's
Angel jug crazy you know what I'm saying
did you ever get an explanation why let
me tell you something bro there was a
book that came out right called jugal
and um we have nothing to do with this
book right this [__] book there
are [__] X jugal I guess or sellout
jugal right whose career it is or was I
don't know to travel around to police
departments and give a seminar on Jugo
identification sh them them all the
[__] labels and and logos crazy you
know what I'm saying and I'm reading
this I know so many jungalow and they're
very very harmless people they're the
most [__] wonderful people like what
what the [__] they're hardworking
American citizens like I don't
understand what the [__] the thing is
you know so what they come from broken
homes you know what the [__] like what
can they do about it you know what I'm
saying like they're they're I don't know
what like I don't know what makes them
any less important of anybody else
people always say oh the only one into
this [__] are the jugs you know what the
[__] are jug right people just
yeah just cuz they have a name it's like
the only one having fun only one liking
ICP is people I just met a guy I met a
guy recently like last week
actually uh my boy who's I won't even
say who he is because you guys might
know him you guys definitely know the
rapper but his his guy who's on the road
with him had a I mean he's just fully
tattooed with like Twisted you guys like
he's [__] and I was like oh you're
jugal he's like I'm a recovering jugal
bro and I was like never heard that
interesting what does that mean I don't
know he's got all the tattoos he's just
a joke or
something I don't know what covering
Jugo is I just was covering so if you
yeah well I want to put a B on the tech
thing because you guys are fine now I
get it now he's dissing us he's saying
like I used to be into that [__] but I'm
I'm off that [__] now whatever oh
so the last time you guys talked who you
and Tech um well man we let me tell you
something then he put out in a song He
said my name in a song you know what I'm
saying and he's talking about Joe Bruce
and um I don't remember how I word it
but it sounded like a [__] disc right
so it was getting really heated up you
know and
um he we talked he I had to [__]
drive to a gas station and I just get
was in my car you know what I'm saying
I'm a taxer he want to he want to get on
the phone yeah yeah so I'm like all
right here we go you know 3 hours bro I
respect the let me say this I respect
the [__] [__] out of that man
he's the best hands down man that
[__] is a real one for sure okay
he talked sense into me he's one of the
realest dudes in the game I always say
that man and he's a humble guy he was
like um
brother you don't want jugal to be
labeled as a gang if me and you fall out
that's exactly what they're going to be
you know what I mean
because you know he was telling me he's
he's he's with the blood he's a blood
and if we go to war you know what I'm
saying it's going to be J against Bloods
and [__] and I just was like The Jug are
a fan base you know what I'm saying and
also they're not out here like that well
this is the thing if you go to a tech
show but they are though bro
Unfortunately they are like that Tech
was like man these got [__]
waiting in line at
meet and greet coming up and trying to
swing on him and [__] like I she big
[__] you know he's telling these
stories to me and he's like he's get he
he uh one of his shows got a bomb thread
or whatever we hadn't even fallen out
right you know what I mean what what is
the website we had even you guys have a
pretty dedicated internet fan base
what's it fol lovers. net they've
covered some of my interviews is it fago
lovers at the F lovers yeah I think so
yeah I I don't know if there's if that's
a website right but they but I know that
they'll like speculate on [__] you know
yeah I don't go there right I don't [__]
with him anymore I used to like them but
uh I don't [__] with I don't go there no
more I don't you know I don't really go
on any websites like that but but but
you guys have that three-hour
conversation and everything yeah it was
intense bro he was like look man you
know I he was like I'm telling you right
now um what was he saying and I was like
do you think I'm afraid of you like he
was like you do not wanna um he said you
do not want to go to war man we we don't
want to go to war over this and I'm like
exactly and um he said something but I
was like do you think I'm soft bro do
you think that's I'm afraid of that to
war with you and he said I
am you know what I mean somehow he put
it like he was like I'm afraid bro we
don't need to be doing this you know
what I mean and it was I don't remember
exactly it was 5 years ago but yeah it
we worked it out man thank God and we
worked it out in that oh and he also put
me up on game about who his whole thing
cuz I I was like bro you know you start
wearing the paint I didn't never seen
them wear the paint until halfway
through the wicked Walker tour right you
know what I'm saying not halfway through
maybe like beginning of it but I I he
wasn't wearing a paint at the beginning
you know so I thought okay he's he's
he's doing what we're doing that's cool
you know what I'm saying so then it's
now it's a thing he still does you know
but he was telling me man I've been
wearing paint since way before you you
know what I'm saying and not before me
but you get what I'm saying since way
before he always kind of went by like
the Killer Clown you know back in the
days exactly you know seen him in no
paint yeah yeah well he was though you
know he he he was um I pictures and [__]
yeah he put me up on game he told me
about his history and everything and um
you knowt it always seemed like you guys
had such a like a shared fan base like
if you go to a tech show I've been to
like probably 50 Tech shows in my life
and you're always going to see jug there
so he was like my security thinks my
security tells me um he said my security
uh says we should just we should uh what
did he say my security says he wants to
kick you some [__] like that right and I
was like [__] that dude you know [__]
him for thinking that you know whatever
his appointment whatever his thing was
anyway so then Tech comes to Detroit on
tour at State Theater and um and I'm
like you know this is all happening
right so anyway we worked it out where
me and Joey are going to go up on stage
and introduce him you know what I'm
saying that's dope yeah so so we went up
there and introduced them on stage you
know but when I got to the venue right
the [__] his security [__] throws me
against the wall you know what I'm
saying OG mugs yeah man like and I'm
like what the [__] y' you know what I'm
saying like get off me he didn't know
what was happening probably right they
knew okay okay they just didn't he was
telling me okay okay his security was
like [__] them dudes you know and I was
like well [__] them tell them [__] you
you know what I mean so uh when I got
there they were rough you know even
though I'm there to make the [__]
piece you know what's crazy is the last
time I saw Tech was last year we were in
Detroit when I told you and he happened
to have a show across the street from
where the Tigers play right by the
Eminem uh restaurant yeah yeah yeah
that's right where I'm talking about
yeah yeah so we went to the show and I I
told I told people like uh you know I'm
from Arizona so we have a certain type
of white trash it's it's we have our own
specific white trash you know but at
that show being in the crowd at a tech
show in Detroit I got to see
Detroit white trash and I was like oh I
got I got it like I got it I was like oh
I get it now like this is like you know
Auto Factory like you know middle of
America Rust Belt [__] is different
you know what I'm
saying white no no I'm saying that I I'm
saying that there's I mean I I'm white
trash you know I'm saying I'm not saying
that I I definitely got to see some
white trash at the tech 9 show not all
of them were white trash what is what is
you know but it was just it was just
funny cuz I was just like you know we
have our own type of white trash like my
family is like bunch of meth heads and
like you know biker dudes that's like
Phoenix white track ain't that everybody
white though that's fair you know
say all that [__] I was just saying the
Detroit white trash was definitely
hitting different I got it I was like yo
it's might have been Eminem if he didn't
make it like standing here watching Tech
9 like you know what I'm saying yeah man
but man yeah he's the [__] man I really
Tech's great man I'm glad you guys
worked that out I didn't I knew you I
knew that there was some sort of like um
like it was out there that you guys had
it might have been an issue but I I you
know I knew it was squashed I just
didn't know the backstory to how that
happened if we were going to go to war
like that we going to come at him hard
of course you know what I mean because
he's so in our integrated in our world
world yeah I'm saying so we weren't just
gonna you know but no of course yeah but
that's the first time I saw him was on
the wicked walking uh the wicked Wonka
tour at Mesa Amphitheater it was what
was that you guys Bone Thugs Cotton
Mouth Kings and Tech yeah and
uh and E I wasn't on there Tech go you
didn't do none of the dates you were on
the [__] Halloween song with us